[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRENT GLEESON: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
How are you guys doing today?
People, we're going to
do burpees and push-ups
until morale improves in here.
Let's try that again.
How are you guys doing today?
AUDIENCE: Good!
BRENT GLEESON: You guys
fired up to be here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
BRENT GLEESON: All right.
I just want to make
sure you guys are
awake and energized, engaged.
I want to make sure I don't get
the sleepy after-lunch crowd.
You know how that
can go sometimes.
And the reason I ask is
because in the early days
of SEAL training, you spend
a hell of a lot of time
in the classroom.
You're basically getting
a PhD in Special Warfare.
But of course, you do
so on very little sleep.
So the instructors would keep
these large metal bathtubs
full of ice water in
the back of the room.
Guess what those were for?
Yeah, that's right.
You know where I'm
going with this.
If you got caught nodding
off, falling asleep,
not paying attention,
you got to sit chest deep
in a bathtub full of ice
water for the rest of class.
Yeah.
Not a head dunk.
Not for one or two minutes.
For the rest of class.
Let me tell you, it's really
hard to learn anything
when you're shivering
your ass off, reaching
hypothermic levels, in a
bathtub full of ice water.
Now, how the hell
do I know that?
Yes, unfortunately, I spent
many, many days and hours
in those ice baths, clearly
not learning from my mistakes
the first time around.
And in light of being fully
transparent with all of you,
I did, in fact, request
ice baths for this event.
Fortunately for
all of you, you're
overprotective human resources
department denied my request,
so you're off the hook.
But I'll be watching you.
No, in all honesty, thank
you so much for having me.
It's really a pleasure and
honor to be here with all of you
this afternoon.
So when a SEAL platoon is on
patrol in enemy territory,
sneaking into an enemy
compound, the man in front
is the point man.
He's taking point.
Leading his team into what
we call VUCA environments.
And yes, that's one
of the many hundreds
if not thousands of acronyms
we have in the United States
military, and it refers to the
volatile, uncertain, complex,
and ambiguous environments
that we operate in.
Sounds like life, right?
And although Navy
SEALs are widely known
to be the most elite and
feared special operations
fighting force in
the entire world,
we've been living in a
constant state of VUCA,
of pain, of loss,
sacrifice and disruption,
in our post-911 reality.
Yet how have we continued
to persevere, adapt,
and lean into that
pain and sacrifice,
to fight and defeat a very
dangerous and decentralized
enemy?
In large part, it's due to our
very well-defined and distinct
organizational
culture, a culture
where every single person
pushes the limits and boundaries
of their comfort zone
every single day.
We get comfortable
being uncomfortable.
Or as we say in the SEAL
teams, we embrace the suck.
And that's what we're going
to talk about today, how
to succeed by living a life
outside of your comfort zone.
Because if you really
think about it,
that's where the
magic really happens.
It's not living in the
confines of your comfort zone.
And when you can
push the boundaries
of your own personal comfort
zone just a little bit,
every single day, the
wider that area becomes.
And the things that
you used to fear,
the things that
seemed uncomfortable,
or the things that seemed
almost seemingly impossible,
they become a part of
your everyday life.
And that winning mindset of
persistence and determination
reminds me of a great
quote by Martin Luther King
Jr. That says, "if you
can't fly, you run.
If you can't run, you walk.
If you can't walk, you
crawl, but no matter
what, you keep moving forward."
In the SEAL teams, we have
an ethos, a creed that
embodies our culture
and our values,
and a similar line from that
ethos says, I will not quit.
I persevere and
thrive in adversity.
And if knocked down, I will
get back up every time.
I am never out of the fight.
And that winning mindset is
how each and every one of you,
all of us, can continue to
take point in our own lives,
to push the confines
of our comfort zone,
to push the limits, to take
calculated risks to succeed
and win, and to be
all in, all the time.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
All right.
What do you think?
Does that remind you of
your workplace environments?
Maybe on Mondays, right?
Being all in all the time is
one of the many philosophies
we hold dear in the SEAL teams.
That phrase was
originally coined
by one of our fallen
SEAL Team 6 team leaders,
his name was Tommy Valentine.
And when he would indoctrinate
new guys into the team,
he would sit them
down and ask them
about what they thought
their level of participation
on the team should be.
Now, of course, there
was only one answer, that
is to be all in all the time.
That is part of our
culture and mindset
and how we approach
our work, our lives.
Simply put, it's about
persistence, determination,
giving every single thing
we do everything we've got
and nothing less.
We too, all of us, can
embody that winning mindset.
And each and every one of
you can take away from this
how to embody that winning
mindset to get comfortable
being uncomfortable to win
and to be all in all the time.
Well, it was December
of 1999 when I first
made my decision to be all in.
As sometimes happens in a
fit of youthful foolishness
and indiscretion, I quit
my corporate finance job
and joined the
United States Navy
with the dream of becoming
a SEAL, a decision,
of course, that would
forever change my life
and set me on the path
that I'm on today.
So this afternoon, I
would like to share
a little bit of that
journey with you,
share some stories from
training, from the battlefield,
so to speak.
But more importantly, I want
to share some experiences
from both literal and
figurative battlefields
about overcoming
adversity, about being
able to adapt your mindset
and approach to life, to work,
and hopefully give you guys
some little bit of entertainment
and maybe even some
insights, key takeaways,
and God willing, maybe even
a little bit of inspiration
you can apply to your own
lives, both personally
and professionally.
So let's dive in, shall we?
Do you guys want to
do burpees, or what?
[LAUGHTER]
BRENT GLEESON: Let's
try that one more time.
Let's dive in, shall we?
AUDIENCE: Yes!
BRENT GLEESON: All right.
Now, as a bit of
background, I grew up
in the great nation of Texas.
Do we have any
Texans in the room?
Not one damn Texan
in the whole room.
You guys have got to be kidding.
I wore my boots for you guys.
I'm wearing boots at Google.
A little fun fact for you guys.
At any given time, about
one third of all SEALs
are from the great
state of Texas.
Now, I know you're a very
data-driven organization.
Please don't go fact
checking that data.
But I'm sure it's accurate.
I just really, really
want to believe it.
So I grew up in Dallas.
I was a swimmer in high school,
played rugby in college.
I attended Southern Methodist
University, Oxford University,
ultimately, earning degrees
in finance and economics.
So naturally, upon
graduation, I took a job
as an entry-level
financial analyst
with a big investment firm.
And during that time, I
had a close friend of mine
in college who is
now a senior at SMU,
and I was working out
in corporate America.
Now he was, in fact, one of
these guys who had a vision.
A lofty, and let's face it,
highly unrealistic vision
of becoming a SEAL.
It was his passion, his purpose
in life, his reason for being.
I thought it was a little
bit ridiculous at the time,
but we started
training together.
I wanted to find
a way to stay fit
while I was working in
finance, prepare a friend
for an arduous journey.
So we started spending a lot
of time together, and of course
having a lot of dialogue
about the history
of the SEAL teams, the Naval
Special Warfare community.
I read one book, the I read
another book and another book.
And I became, over time,
enthralled and fascinated
by their high-performance
culture and mindset
and approach to their work
and life, their core values.
And over time, with all the
training and the studying
of the Naval Special
Warfare community,
obviously, my close friends
and family and colleagues
started realizing
this growing passion
for my own possible rather
dynamic career path shift.
So one day, I was
having a conversation
with my twin brother.
I'll preface this by saying
we're fraternal twins.
We are polar opposites in
just about every possible way.
But I did want to run this
idea by him before I ran it
up the chain of
command to mom and dad,
who would no doubt be a little
shocked by this dramatic shift.
And you know what he was doing,
supportive brother that he
is, that's right.
He was laughing his ass off.
He's like, Brent, you've
got to be kidding me.
SEALS?
Like, you're not
being serious, right?
I'll admit, I don't even
really know much about it,
but I know one thing.
There is no way in hell
you could ever do that.
I mean, let's face it.
Aren't these guys supposed to
be, I don't know, world-class
warriors or something?
Really tough guys?
You are not tough at all.
I mean, let's break
it down, here.
Well, yeah.
Well, you have allergies.
Really bad allergies.
And asthma.
You're literally
wheezing right now,
and there's a
tissue on the floor.
Is that yours?
You wear those thick
contact lenses.
You can't see shit.
How is that going to work?
And remember last week?
You forgot I thought about
this, but remember last week,
when you cried a little bit
during that TV commercial?
Again, don't know
much about it, but I'm
pretty certain SEALs
are nerdy, sniffly,
emotional guys who cry during
a Clorox bleach commercial.
So let's just forget we
had this conversation
and stick with your
nerdy finance job.
Well, now I knew I
had to do it, right?
This is a true story.
Literally a week
later, I quit my job,
and my buddy, whom I'd
been training with,
moved up here to Crested
Butte, Colorado, where
we trained for an additional
six months for five hours a day
at 10,000 feet altitude
to get into the best
physical condition
that we could.
Then in early 2000,
joined the Navy,
and after a couple of
months of basic training,
was on a plane, headed
out to sunny San Diego,
California, where we
would begin our journey.
And I can tell you with
exact certainty and clarity,
like it was yesterday,
that I have never
been more nervous
in my entire life
than the day I stepped foot into
the lobby of the Naval Special
Warfare Training Center.
Because it is a very scary and
depressing thing, my friends.
Knowing for a fact--
for a fact, Matt--
that your life is going
to be pure hell and misery
for many months to come.
But of course, at this point,
there was no turning back.
I had to be all in.
And let's put our talent
acquisition and employee
retention hats on for a minute.
I'll tell you another
interesting fact.
It takes 18 months and
costs about $3 million
to acquire one SEAL,
and that doesn't
count the millions of dollars
and years of arduous training
once you actually
make it to a team.
That 18 months is broken
into various segments.
The first segment is six
months long and called BUD/S,
another one of our acronyms.
It stands for Basic
Underwater Demolition SEAL.
If any of you have
seen the SEAL movie,
"Lone Survivor,"
it's unfortunately
based on a true story.
The opening scenes are actually
from a Discovery Channel
documentary about
BUD/S class 234.
We run six classes a year,
so every two months, I
follow them in class 235.
I was present for
all this filming,
and this will give
you guys just a teeny,
tiny taste of what
BUD/S is all about.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- 6 times 3.
- [GROANS]
- Hurry up.
Hurry up.
- It's uh, it's eight--
18!
- Ooh!
- Ring the bell three times.
Put your helmet on the ground.
You're done.
- Move it, you maggot!
You do it again!
- Have you been tested this
hard ever in your life?
- Never.
- Winning here is a
conscious decision.
Make up your mind whether you
want to pass or choose to fail.
- All right now, gentlemen.
I'm going to introduce you
all to something called
"not being able to breathe."
- Andrew!
Come back!
Come back to the light!
- Take all this shaking and
all this cold, harness it.
Turn it into aggression.
You just proved to your
bodies through your mind
that you can push
yourself further
than you thought possible.
- You'll get wet!
Run!
- I met my limit, so that's it.
- Are you sure you
want to be here?
- Yes, I do.
- Are you absolutely sure?
- [INAUDIBLE]!
- Whatever you have to do!
- Just find an excuse to win!
Keep going!
- It pays to be a winner!
- I like having my buddies
that I can depend on,
and I would like for them
to be able to depend on me.
- The guys are our
band of brothers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Silent night.
Holy night.
All is calm.
All is bright.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BRENT GLEESON:
Doesn't that look fun?
Does anybody feel like they
missed their calling in life?
Anybody age 30 or younger,
come see me afterwards, please.
Didn't think I was going to use
this as a recruiting platform,
did you?
But now that I think
about it, that video
probably really damages my
recruiting possibility here
at Google.
Now, the funny thing
is what you just saw
was a depiction of only the
first three weeks of BUD/S.
BUD/S has a 90% failure rate
of highly capable candidates.
None of us are extraordinary,
exceptional individuals.
We're just common people with
an uncommon desire to succeed.
So imagine those types of
activities going on for months
and months at a time.
And then the irony, Wendy,
is that the training just
gets more difficult after that.
That's the funny part.
It's actually not that funny.
If you think about that, that
mindset, that winning mindset,
to highlight that, I want to
focus on some of the things
you heard the instructors
saying to the students
in those video clips.
Where he said,
gentlemen, winning here
is a conscious decision.
You will make up your mind
whether you want to pass,
or you're going
to choose to fail.
Keep moving no matter what.
Find an excuse to win.
You can push yourself further
than your mind or body ever
thought possible.
BUD/S training is based
on the rule of seven.
When your brain is telling
you that you can go no further
and take no more pain, you
can go seven times longer,
seven times more, and push
yourself seven times harder.
And again, that's why
very few people make it
through this selection process.
And when we think about
that winning mindset
when we approach our
life and our goals,
setting those lofty
goals, that lofty vision,
we've all done that in
various aspects of our life.
We set that lofty
goal, and we have
to work backwards to find
our own path to success.
Elite athletes do this.
Elite warriors do it.
Each and every one of you has
done it, whether you realize it
or not, at various stages of
your life, to achieve goals
academically, in
your personal life,
in athletics, to land a job here
at Google, which what I hear
is not an easy thing to do.
That's a lofty
vision, a lofty goal.
It took a lot of hard
work to get here.
Same thing when I
made that decision
to transition from
corporate finance
to start training and join
the Navy to become a SEAL.
A total mindset transformation.
I had to think about the
reality of the world around me
in a totally different way.
Everything had to
change in order for me
to achieve that lofty goal of a
program that has a 90% failure
rate.
Let's take public speaking,
for example, Steve.
People always ask
me, well, how did
you get into this part
of your profession?
The public speaking,
and do you enjoy it.
I mean, who likes
public speaking?
Nobody.
It's like the number
one fear of most people.
And it's kind of a funny story.
It started in graduate school.
I actually started my
MBA program one week
after I got on the SEAL teams.
And literally, a month
into this program,
I was doing my very first
group class presentation,
and I got up for my portion,
and I had some notes.
My hands were shaking.
I'm like-- and I was sweating.
I'm like, I'm a Navy
SEAL combat veteran.
I was standing in front
a classroom of 50 people,
and my hands were
shaking, and I'm sweating.
I'm terrified.
But I kind of enjoyed
it at the same time.
And several years later,
it was December of 2012,
it was a Saturday morning,
and I opened my laptop.
I was checking my email.
And right there at
the top the Inbox
was an email, personally,
from the President
of Bank of America, Merrill
Lynch Asia-Pacific, one
of the top four executives in
the entire global organization.
And he explained to me that he
had read the first article I'd
written for my Forbes column,
literally a month before this,
which was titled,
"From the Battlefield
to the Boardroom,
a Navy SEAL's Guide
to Business Leadership Success."
This guy is a highly
energetic banking prodigy,
an Australian guy.
Super into fitness.
Super obsessed with
Special Operations culture.
He's like, I really
love how you draw
these correlations, these
cultural values and principles,
then you can apply those to
building winning cultures
and winning teams in
the business world.
And he went on to
invite me to do
a series of keynote
presentations and workshops
at their Global Leadership
Conference in Hong Kong
the following month.
He didn't ask if
I was a speaker.
Didn't ask to see a website.
Didn't ask to see any videos.
Didn't ask for client
testimonials, nothing.
As silly as this sounds, just
the fact that I was a SEAL
was enough for him.
But of course, being
the entrepreneur that I
am, I was like, hell, yeah.
Of course I'll come
out there and speak
to all you people in Hong Kong.
Sent the email back,
and I closed my laptop,
and I turned to my
office, like, oh, shit.
What the hell did
I just commit to?
I don't know how
to be a speaker.
But I had enough content.
I built some presentations
based on various discovery
calls we had, and I
prepared relentlessly.
Living outside your comfort zone
and pushing those boundaries
cannot succeed without
discipline and accountability.
So I prepared and rehearsed
and rehearsed and rehearsed,
practice, practice, practice,
and I went out there,
went on stage for
the first keynote,
knowing that I had
several other talks,
and I was doing breakout
sessions throughout the day.
It was exhausting.
Go up on stage.
Of course, once
again, I'm terrified.
But again, I had
rehearsed and prepared so
relentlessly that
it went very well.
They had me back to Singapore
and Sydney the following month.
I've done that Asia-Pacific
tour every year since then,
and I've doubled the frequency
of speaking engagements
every year over
the past six years.
I speak about 75 times a year.
Those early years, it
was always uncomfortable.
I always had to get comfortable
being uncomfortable.
It was always terrifying
getting on stage.
I was always nervous.
My wife would always
say-- because she
used to travel with me
before all of our children--
and she'd say, honey, I
like you so much better
after you're done talking.
She'd be trying to talk to me,
and I'd just be in the zone.
I wouldn't even answer her.
I couldn't even
hear her talking.
But I found a passion for it.
Even though it
was uncomfortable,
I pushed myself beyond
that comfort zone
to do something that
I had a passion for,
that I had a desire
to continue to do.
At any time in our life, when
we have that vision, that vision
and that lofty
goal, just like we
say in the SEAL teams
and other areas of life,
we have to break that lofty
goal, that lofty vision,
break it down.
In the SEAL teams,
we say, you've
got to eat the elephant
one bite at a time.
You break the big goals
into bite-sized chunks,
making them less daunting
and more achievable.
Navy SEALs can only be
forged in adversity.
Every single person
in this room has
and will continue to face
various aspects of adversity
throughout your entire life.
But again, as you
know, it's what we do
and how we react in the
face of adversity that
builds our character
and defines who we are.
So the third week of
BUD/S, the third week
of this 18-month training
pipeline is called Hell Week.
And I assure you, it's a
lot worse than that sounds.
Actually, that sounds
pretty bad, doesn't it?
Hell Week?
It's designed to do one
thing, simply weed out
those not committed to the
vision of becoming a SEAL.
You do not sleep
for an entire week.
You run the equivalent
of multiple marathons
while wet and sandy,
inside and out.
This is called getting
a sugar cookie.
It sucks.
Because the instructors make
a concerted effort to ensure
you get the sand on the
inside of your clothing,
so that it strips the flesh
off your body as you run.
It's like wearing
sandpaper inside out.
It does.
It's very effective.
You swim dozens of miles
in the open, frigid ocean.
You run with heavy logs,
heavy boats, heavy backpacks.
You run the obstacle course
multiple times a day.
Endless calisthenics.
Brutal beatings.
All while battling severe
bruising, cuts, lacerations,
stress fractures, cellulitis,
broken bones, the most
severe chafing,
people, you could ever
imagine, in all of the
areas you would never,
ever want to be severely chafed.
In fact, calling it chafing
is not even accurate.
You literally have--
I'm sorry, but I'm
going to say it anyways,
you have no skin left between
your legs, around your waist,
in your armpits, and on
the top of your head.
And then imagine
all the extra time
you spend in the saltwater.
It really kicks it up a notch.
Oh, and one more thing.
And.
pretty much constant
second-stage hypothermia.
So bearing all that in mind,
let's do the math really quick.
This is a picture of
my graduating class,
intentionally grainy to
preserve people's identities.
But about 1,000 guys
applied for our BUD/S class.
We run six classes a year.
Of that 1,000, only 250 were
selected to begin training.
Of that 250, only 23
graduated, earning the right
to wear the SEAL trident pin.
Now, the interesting
thing about this pin
is that it's the only emblem
in the United States military
where the Eagle's
head is fully bowed.
Bowed in memory of those that
forged the path ahead of us.
Bye.
Everybody say good bye.
[LAUGHS] Thank you.
Another line from the SEAL
ethos says, my trident
is a symbol of honor and
heritage bestowed upon me
by the heroes that
have gone before.
It embodies the trust of those
that I am bound to defend.
It is a privilege we
must earn every day.
Your roles, for
example, as members
of this team of this
amazing organization,
is a privilege each of you
have to earn every single day,
simply by asking yourself,
what will I do today
to be the best, most
valuable, and effective member
of this organization
that I can be.
Which we say in
the SEAL teams, how
will I earn my trident today?
So after several combat
tours, I left the SEAL teams,
went to graduate
school, and decided
to become an entrepreneur,
another very uncomfortable
thing.
I didn't have any money saved
after being in the Navy.
It's like working
for free, people.
I had student loans.
We started a company.
And basically, the first
company I started right out
of graduate school
was, essentially,
an early version
of Trulia, Zillow,
it was a home finding
search engine.
The housing market was booming.
The economy was booming.
We knew this ride was
never going to end.
This housing bubble was
never going to burst.
We raised $2 million
with this business.
We kept growing it.
We probably spent
$200,000 a month
in Google AdWords, because
our SEO rankings sucked.
I had to learn how to become an
SEO expert, which we all know
is impossible, because you
change the algorithm every 30
seconds.
Thanks a lot, guys-- oh, see?
I just blacked out.
I went off on a tangent.
All our rankings dropped.
We had to spend $200,000
a month in AdWords.
So you're welcome.
You're welcome.
And then 2008 came around.
Anybody remember what
happened in 2008?
The global economy collapsed.
The housing market
was destroyed.
All of our advertisers
cut their--
you know, what's
the first budget
to go when there's
an economic downturn?
Marketing, of course.
We got hammered.
There was a lot of
pain, a lot of struggle,
a lot of adversity, a lot
of crying, mostly by me,
unfortunately, in
front of people.
And it wasn't really until I
had to reflect back on and lean
into some of those
principles and that mindset
that got me through SEAL
training, that got me
through hundreds and
hundreds of combat missions
and the loss of many friends,
and really reflecting
on the culture and values
that forged SEAL culture
and how we could apply
those principles in building
a winning organization that was
resilient, that would bounce
back from this adversity.
We also leaned in
to the principle
that we hold dear in the
SEAL teams of adaptability.
So we diversified ourselves.
We had learned so much about
digital marketing and media
that we decided to start a
digital marketing agency.
So we borrowed $100,000
from the first business
to start the second business,
gave those shareholders
equal common stock shares
in the new company,
and that company
doubled in size--
using those principles
I just talked about--
doubled in size every year
until we sold it a year
and a half ago.
But even that company
went through a lot
of change, a lot of
organizational transformation.
You're talking about a
fast-growing company in an even
more rapidly changing industry,
mostly chasing your Google
algorithm, again, thank you.
But again, all
those principles can
be applied to building winning
teams, winning organizations,
and of course, succeeding
in life in general.
And that's kind of what I wanted
to talk about in more detail
today.
I had a failing
company at that time.
Starting a new business.
All those things causing
a lot of pain, adversity.
I was CEO of two companies,
not an easy thing to do.
And then more
adversity came along.
It usually comes in
threes, for some reason.
Anybody know that about life?
When something shitty
happens, two more things
are coming, so get ready.
I'll spare you the details,
but during that time,
I was trying to save
a failing business
and start a new business and
make that business successful.
I was literally transformed
into a full-time single parent
to a two-year-old overnight.
Anybody in here have kids?
It sucks, man.
[LAUGHS] I'm like, where
does Mommy keep your stuff?
[LAUGHS] I would drop them
off at school with no shoes.
It was a disaster.
But the point of
telling you this
is sometimes in life, when
we face adversity, we also
have to make very difficult
and humbling decisions
to do what's best
for our family,
to do what's best for the
organizations we're a part of.
So what I ended
up having to do is
making the decision to step down
as CEO of that second company.
I knew I could not effectively
lead that organization,
even though I tried.
I had to shift my
priorities to my son.
But again, that was a
very uncomfortable thing.
It was something that was
outside my comfort zone.
But then the magic happened.
I was able to place
myself in a role I
was very passionate about in the
organization as chief marketing
officer.
And that company continued to
thrive, and things got better.
And then something else
happened a few years later.
I had an opportunity to
go to one of two weddings.
One was a wedding in Houston
for one of my best friends
from college and
high school, another
was a wedding in
Costa Rica for one
of my best SEAL team buddies.
Wedding in Houston,
wedding in Costa Rica,
where do you guys think I went?
Costa Rica.
The day I got to Costa Rica
was the day I met my wife.
I literally told her two days
into that wedding weekend
that we were going
to get married.
Taking a little
calculated risk, right?
I knew that would do
one of two things,
scare the crap out of her and
send her running for the hills,
or maybe marginally
intrigue her enough
to continue the conversation.
A month later-- this is a true
story too-- a month later,
we got matching tattoos--
before the ring.
We got matching tattoos.
Two months after
that, we got engaged,
and a after that,
we got married.
And now we have two
more beautiful children
and are happy as can be.
But again, it's about taking
that calculated risk in life,
whether it's in our work,
in our personal lives,
in our relationships, but
living outside your comfort zone
and finding any level of success
really cannot happen, ever,
without extremely high levels
of discipline and accountability
and follow through.
The concept of accountability
in SEAL training
starts on day one.
And as we say, our
training is never complete.
So from the very first
week of training,
throughout the entire
18-month training process,
we perform a weekly--
what I refer to as an
accountability drill.
We're essentially teaching
ourselves and our teammates
to hold each other to the
highest level of standard.
The highest level
of accountability.
It's a wonderful,
fascinating, weekly evolution
called The Top
Five, Bottom Five.
So every Friday afternoon,
before the class
is secured for the weekend,
they bring the class
into the classroom.
They sit you down,
and the instructors
pass out blank sheets of
paper, and on that paper
are five lines on the top
and five lines on the bottom.
And you are instructed
to anonymously rank
who you believe the top five
performers are in the class
and who you believe
the bottom five
performers are in the class.
I know you're thinking, from
a human resources perspective,
wow, that's probably
pretty cool.
No.
They never tell you
who the top five are,
because people, that would
be positive reinforcement.
And we do not deal in positive
reinforcement in SEAL training.
We deal only in
negative reinforcement.
So what they do do
is they tally up
all the names in the bottom
five and post them right there
on the white board
next to the door.
Not a great way to
start your weekend.
The one name most frequently
listed in the bottom five
every Friday until
the end of training
is immediately
ejected from training,
based on peer evaluations.
No ifs, ands, or buts, no
appealing to the empathies
of the human resources
department, because we do not
have a human resources
department in SEAL training.
But we take this concept
of accountability
extremely seriously.
We take it with us
to the battlefield.
When you're on patrol in enemy
territory, each and every man
is accountable, for example,
for owning a field of fire.
The area you are
responsible for protecting,
should the enemy attack.
And that's the great thing
about accountability,
especially in a team setting,
is because when everyone
is accountable, everybody
is executing their duties
to the best of
their ability, you
don't have to worry
about anything outside
of your own field of fire.
Accountability is equally
as important in a team
setting as it is in
a personal setting.
We're trying to achieve goals.
As you can imagine, when I
decided to make that lofty leap
and take that risk to quit
my rather lucrative finance
job to join the Navy and try
out for the SEAL program,
knowing that there was a high,
high, high likelihood that I
would never make it, again,
it was a total mindset
transformation with
that lofty vision.
But again, like I've said,
you cannot achieve those lofty
goals, pushing outside
your comfort zone,
without extremely high levels of
accountability and discipline.
Every night I would come home
from the office about 6:30 PM,
throw on a backpack,
running shoes,
the backpack had fins
and goggles in it.
I would run four miles to
the SMU pool, swim a mile,
then run four miles home.
On the weekends, we'd run
marathons, do various spring
training activities.
I did this for an entire year
while I was working in finance,
and then as you know, we moved
up to Crested Butte, Colorado,
and trained, again,
for five hours a day
at 10,000 feet altitude.
But doing all that required
an extremely high level
of focus and discipline
and accountability,
because I had to
transform my entire life
to mold it around
achieving this vision.
My social life had to change.
My dietary habits had to change.
My fitness regime had to change.
I did it, of
course, responsibly.
I wasn't shutting out
loved ones from my life,
but I did shut out
a lot of people
that didn't need to
be in my life that
would stand in the way of
me achieving that goal.
My social life
changed dramatically.
But again, all these things,
accountability, discipline,
are critical for living a
life beyond your comfort zone
and achieving those lofty
goals we have set in our lives.
Let these pictures
sink in for one second.
Studies actually show that
interacting with animals
can actually improve human
social interaction in the areas
of trust and empathy.
So I thought these pictures
were appropriate for the trust
slide.
Yes, that is a
monkey on my head.
My last tour was in Africa.
His name is Iron Mike.
I raised him from infancy.
I found him on the
side of the road.
His mom was injured.
And at night, he would
sleep in my cot with me,
either nestled in my
armpit or on my chest.
And in the morning, he
would wake up and crawl up
onto my chin, grab my
eyelashes, and rip my eyes open.
Like, hey, Dad!
It's time to eat!
You people in the
room who have kids
know that our children
basically do something similar
every frickin' morning.
My two-year-old came in
the morning, 5 o'clock,
two days ago, with a hat
and sunglasses and a diaper
on, also demanding to eat.
And yes, that is a dog
attached to my body
as I jump out of the
back of that plane.
You know what he's
thinking right now?
Man's best friend, my ass.
Not a happy--
I don't know what it is about
plummeting 130 miles an hour
towards the face of the Earth.
It takes a little
getting used to.
They don't particularly
care for it.
I know there's a lot
of dog lovers in here.
I'm a dog lover.
I have three myself.
Trust me, these dogs
get taken care of a lot
better than we do.
They stay in their own
hotel rooms at the W
when we go on training trips.
So don't worry about these dogs.
They're fully taken care of.
I wanted to tell you
guys a brief story
about trust from my BUD/S
class' Hell Week experience.
Hell Week, again,
the brutal crucible
that all SEALs share
that few pass, Hell Week
starts on a Sunday and
ends on a Friday afternoon.
And the beauty of that Sunday
is that the whole class
will report to the
classroom with only
a couple required items
in their possession.
And the amazing thing
about this Sunday
is that the students
have no idea when
Hell Week will commence.
The anxiety, the
anguish is literally
eating away at your soul.
You know it's probably going to
be the worst week of your life,
and you just want it to start.
That's the weird
paradox of it all.
And as a way to inspire us and
motivate us, our class leader,
who is the highest ranking
officer in the class,
he read to us the St. Crispin's
Day speech from William
Shakespeare's "Henry V."
And he read aloud those famed
lines that say, "we few,
we happy few, we
band of brothers.
For he today that
sheds his blood with me
shall be my brother."
John died four days later.
We were four and 1/2
days into Hell Week.
There were only about 30
students left of the 250.
We were in full gear, no fins,
in an Olympic-sized swimming
pool, doing relay races.
And we were performing
an evolution
called The Caterpillar
Race, which
is not as cute as it sounds.
Your boat crew of seven
guys is in the water,
in a line, swimming
backwards, like this.
Except I would have
my legs wrapped
around the waist of
the guy in front of me,
his legs are wrapped around
the waist of the guy in front
of him, and so on and so forth.
Now, even fresh, this is
a very difficult evolution
to execute properly, much less
to beat the other boat crew
to the other side of the pool.
Everything in Hell
Week is a race.
Four and 1/2 days
into Hell Week,
you're hallucinating so
violently, your body is
so brutally beaten, it's
more of an evolution
in controlled drowning.
Long story short, John suffered
a massive heart failure
and drowned in the
pool right next to us.
But again, we were hallucinating
so violently and so exhausted
at that point, nobody had
any idea what was going on.
So they ran us back
across the street
to the Special Warfare
Center, and they
put us in the classroom, where
we waited for a couple hours.
After a couple of
hours, the door opens,
and the instructor staff
walked in, and with them was
the commanding officer
of BUD/S at the time.
He walked to the front of
the room, turned around
to address the class.
He said, gentlemen, listen up.
Lieutenant John Skop was
pronounced dead at 1:00 AM.
Lieutenant Barado,
you're taken over.
And he said it with that
level of candor, I believe,
purposefully.
He paused for a minute
to let that sink in.
Then he said, gentlemen,
get used to this feeling
that you have right now.
This is what it's going
to be like in the teams.
And you will lose teammates.
You have to learn to
control your emotions,
stay focused on the mission,
and trust each other no matter
what, especially
amidst adversity.
And it was a bit of
odd foreshadowing,
because he really had no
idea how right he really was.
Literally four months
later was 9/11, and that's
when we all knew
we'd be going to war,
where trust would
be at a premium.
When you think about the notion
of trust, like accountability
in a team setting, obviously
critically important,
the trust all of
you have for one
another as team members
of this organization,
the trust you build
with the customer,
with your friends,
your family, and
your relationships.
As we all know,
trust is the bedrock
of any sound relationship.
It takes a long time to
build and moments to break.
And it's equally as important
in an individual setting,
especially when we're
talking about living
a life outside your comfort
zone and setting and achieving
those lofty goals.
The trust you have in yourself
to fulfill the promises you
make to yourself to
achieve those goals,
to be disciplined
and accountable.
And like
accountability, trust is
the bedrock of any successful
purpose-driven life.
It's how you fuel the drive
to achieve those goals.
It's how you shut out the
noise and the naysayers who
want to stand in the
way of you achieving
your goals and your dreams.
It builds resilience,
and resilience
is the foundation of any life
lived outside your comfort
zone.
In closing, I want to share
a short poem with you guys.
There's a poem that's widely
shared in the Naval Special
Warfare community.
It was authored
by Chief Tecumseh.
He was a Shawnee chief
from the War of 1812.
It's shared widely
in our community.
It's part of our culture.
It speaks to how we
approach our life, our work,
it's how we honor our fallen.
And I've, of course,
seen many things in life.
I've experienced the war-torn
countries around the world.
I've been to more funerals
than I can remember.
I've lost more friends
And I've taken life.
And even though this poem
is called "Death Song,"
it's a metaphor for living
a purpose-driven life.
"So live your life
so the fear of death
may never enter your heart.
Trouble no one about
their religion.
Respect others and their views,
and demand that they respect
yours.
Love your life.
Perfect your life.
Unify all things in your life.
Seek to make your life long
and of service to your people.
Prepare a noble death
song for the day
you go over the great divide.
Show respect to all
people, but grovel to none.
When you arise in the morning,
give thanks for the light,
for your life and strength.
If you see no reason
for giving thanks,
the fault lies within yourself.
When your time
comes to die, be not
like those whose hearts are
filled with the fear of death,
so they weep.
They pray for a little more time
to live their lives over again
in a different way.
Sing your death song, and
die like a hero going home.
Now, again, I know that
poem is titled "Death Song,"
but if you listen to those
words, it's not about death,
is it?
It's about life.
Living our lives to
the fullest extent.
Creating, seizing
every opportunity
we have to be better,
to achieve more, and not
for our own selfish desires,
for the organizations we're
a part of, for our teams, our
families, our communities,
bettering the lives
of those around us,
and hopefully one day making
this world a little bit better
place than we found it.
So ladies and gentlemen,
as you step forth
onto your own
battlefield of life,
setting and achieving
those lofty goals,
pushing the boundaries
of your comfort zone,
and achieving
maximum performance,
remember these three things.
Get comfortable
being uncomfortable.
Push the boundaries
of your comfort zone
every single chance you get,
because the more you do,
the wider that area
becomes, and that is truly
where the magic happens.
Next, remember, as we
say in the SEAL teams--
we have a hell of a lot
of sayings, people--
the only easy day was yesterday.
There truly are no easy days
for high-performance teams
and driven
individuals to achieve
an existence of excellence.
Life is full of challenges.
We simply have to face those
challenges head on, controlling
what we can and
ignoring what we can't.
The last thing, my
friends, I ask that you
be all in all the time.
Ask yourself every
day, at what level
am I willing to participate
on this team and in this life.
And no matter what
challenges life
throws your way,
whether they be at work,
at home, your family, spouse,
kids, even things like divorce,
illness, finances,
no matter what it is.
Not if, but when you get knocked
down, get back up every time,
and never ever be
out of the fight.
God bless you guys.
Good luck in your
life's journey.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
AUDIENCE: The bottom-ranked
individuals that [INAUDIBLE]..
What characteristic [INAUDIBLE]?
BRENT GLEESON: It's
a good question.
Because typically, from
those peer reviews--
BUD/S is a very
level playing field.
We have Olympic athletes
who quit in the first minute
of Hell Week.
We have guys who look like
some accountant who crush you
at a 15-mile ruck run.
But typically, the data
points that come out
of those anonymous
peer-to-peer surveys
are more character-driven.
Your moral compass is off.
You've got an ego problem.
You're not a team player.
You're not a collaborator.
Basically, somebody who is
not a trustworthy person, who
you would not want to be
standing next to in a gunfight.
That's what gets those people
dropped out of BUD/S, more
frequently than
performance drops,
more frequently than quitting.
When it comes down to
performance evaluation,
if you're not the best
shooter on a shooting range,
you're having trouble
with ocean swims,
they'll typically
work with you if you
have a sound moral
compass, and they
believe that you'll
be a great culture
fit for our organization.
But when those-- and
the instructors now,
they use iPads now.
They had clipboards
back in my day.
But they have this scale in
this algorithm they created,
where one on one bar
of the scale, there
is your physical and tactical
abilities that are needed
as a SEAL, and the rest is
culture and moral values,
and that's what
gets people dropped
is that they don't
think you're going
to be a good fit for
our organization,
or you're not a
trustworthy individual.
It's a good question.
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned that BUD/S
is one of several different--
BRENT GLEESON: Yes.
So you'll go through
BUD/S for six months,
and then the 25 or 30 students
that will graduate from BUD/S
will then go on to SQT, or
SEAL Qualification Training,
which is another year
of advanced training.
So you're doing less getting
your ass kicked, and you're
doing more of the learning
the technical skills
and tactical skills that
you need to be as a SEAL.
So now they bake in
a lot more schools.
They do language
schools, freefall school,
breacher school, some other
things you never used to get.
You'd get those schools later
on, once you get to a team.
But now the guys are coming in
more fit than we've ever seen
them and more qual'ed up.
So they basically hit
the ground running.
Because we have-- there's
only 2,000 active SEALs
in the world at any given
time, yet we have conflicts
all over the world.
It's not just Iraq, Syria,
Afghanistan, it's everywhere.
Places I can't
mention, of course,
but we have more conflicts
and more missions
than we have people.
[LAUGHS] And again,
we're open for business
for you ladies, too.
Remember, three years ago, we
lifted the restriction on women
in the front lines of combat.
I will say we haven't had one
single female applicant yet,
but it will happen someday.
They're out there.
So thank you.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: What are some of the
ways you're making yourself
uncomfortable in civilian life?
BRENT GLEESON: [LAUGHS]
A lot of way to do it--
and this is kind of
also how I prepare.
Because people always-- well,
is BUD/S and SEAL training more
mental, is it more physical.
I believe if you're preparing
for something like this,
my approach was it's
very difficult to prepare
mentally, because
you really don't know
what it's going to be like.
Everybody's journey through SEAL
training is totally different.
But I prepared physically
as relentlessly as possible.
Because when you push your
body as hard as you can,
it increases mental
fortitude and mental strength
and emotional intelligence.
And so that's how I do that.
So I still do that in
life, I approach fitness.
I travel lots, and my
diet is not as good
as it possibly could be, so
I have to work out harder.
And I have three kids,
so chasing those crazies
around is also a
good way to do it.
But again, doing things
like public speaking,
that was something that took
years to really get comfortable
doing.
Where I was always nervous.
I was always fearful.
But now I'm not.
Now I can just focus more
on preparation as opposed
to combating the fear
and anxiety of getting up
in front of an audience, whether
it's 30 people or 3,000 people.
And other things are just taking
calculated risk in business,
in life, in those
personal goals.
The transition to sell the
company a year and a half
ago was a bit of a
risky transition,
to go all in on writing the
book and doing more speaking
and building a consulting
practice around this.
So now I don't have 200
amazing employees anymore.
I have me and a
few other people.
So it's kind of going back
to the drawing board, being
an entrepreneur again, where
it's all on my shoulders
to figure it out.
So it's always taking not
just irresponsible risk,
but calculated risk, and
then working your ass off
to make sure that that
vision is fulfilled.
Thank you.
Who else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So those 90% that
do get cut or quit [INAUDIBLE]
BRENT GLEESON: I always
joke that the SEAL
program is the best recruiting
tool the regular Navy ever had.
You're not going home, people.
You're stuck in the Navy
for four or five years,
doing any job they
want to give you.
Before, in my day,
you had to choose
what's a rate, which is a job.
So a sonar technician
or whatever.
And because 90% those people
need a job and a career path,
and somewhere to place them
after they inevitably fail out
of BUD/S, now SEAL is a rate.
So the problem with
that is it's good
because you're taking
advancement exams based
on the jobs you actually do.
I was a sonar tech.
That's like listening to
little pings in a submarine.
So I took an advancement
test one time in Iraq--
this is going to be a
ding to my character--
but I was like, I don't
know anything about this.
There's no study materials.
I was like, somebody go find
me-- we were at a base in Iraq.
I was like, somebody
find me a sonar tech.
Luckily, there was
some sonar tech there.
And I was like, can we
collaborate a little bit
on this?
I didn't cheat.
He was my study partner.
But the problem with
SEAL being a rate
now is that it's great
for advancement exams,
but now, you don't have a
job coming out of BUD/S,
so the Navy can do whatever they
want with you, which is also,
I would hope, a motivator for
those individuals not to quit,
because you don't know where
they're going to stick you.
Did I answer the question?
Yes.
OK.
Yeah.
Anything else?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Saying all in, all
the time is a wonderful motto,
but it takes its toll.
Can you speak to the
resiliency in that?
BRENT GLEESON: Yes.
The concept of all
in, all the time,
is all about prioritization
and execution.
I get that question a lot.
And when I have time to explain,
it's usually in the Q&A.
But it's not about--
you can't go all
in on everything.
And I don't even like the
concept of multitasking,
because then you're just
doing a whole bunch of things
really crappily.
So it's really all
about prioritization.
So if you can
prioritize those goals
you have in life or in work
or whatever it is, and invest
the appropriate amount
of time and resources
or whatever is needed
into that prioritization,
then you can really go all in.
But you can't say, well, I want
to be an expert guitar player,
and I want to have great
upward mobility at Google,
and I also want to have all
this and all this and this.
You're not going to able to do
all that all in, all the time,
all at once.
It has to be a prioritized
list of the things that
are most important to you, that
you're most passionate about,
or you have a passion
for those things.
Then you're going
to be successful,
because you're going
to willingly put
the work and the time
into being successful.
And then once you've achieved
some level of success
in that field, then maybe
shift to another one
of those priorities.
Good question.
Thank you.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk a little
bit about the role of mentors
and [INAUDIBLE] in your life,
in your experience in the Navy
and otherwise [INAUDIBLE].
BRENT GLEESON: Yes, absolutely.
It's a great question
about mentorship.
When I-- I had a lot of
mentors throughout my life
in high school and college.
But when I told my
parents, hey, I'm
trying for this SEAL
program, they're
like, oh, good luck with that.
But ironically-- and I didn't
even know this at the time--
my dad's best friend in
college, who they swam together,
they also went to SMU--
was a Vietnam-era SEAL, and
he still lived in San Diego.
So he called his
friend Tom up and said,
hey, Brent's joining the Navy.
Can you kind of
talk him out of it?
No.
He's joining the Navy.
When he gets out
there, it'd be great
if you could take
him under your wing,
mentor him a little
bit, tell him
about the community,
the process.
Obviously it changed vastly
since the Vietnam era guys.
He was in BUD/S class 32,
I was in BUD/S class 235.
So years later,
of course, but he
became a phenomenal
mentor for me, so much so
that he actually became
the first investor
of my first business.
So it was a great opportunity
to learn from him,
not just about the
SEAL community,
but about business
and entrepreneurship.
And the downside
was that he also
liked to swim the La Jolla
Cove every morning at 5:00 AM.
And he's my mentor and
investor and my first company,
so guess who also got to swim
the Cove at 5:00 AM every day?
[SIGHS] Anyways.
And then, of course,
in the SEAL teams,
you informally have
other mentors, basically,
the older guys who've been there
longer and seen more stuff.
And it was such a great
part of my experience
that I now mentor young
guys into the program.
I have mentored
seven or eight guys,
and I will say, I'm
seven for seven,
which of course I take
the full credit for.
But it's really neat, because
it's a way of giving back.
I had mentors throughout
my entire life that
really were phenomenal
building blocks for the goals
that I achieved.
And so it's also a way
that I give back now.
Because I get, through social
media and things like that,
I have high school kids
all the time saying, hey,
I want to go to BUD/S. And I'm
like, oh God, here we go again.
Like, you're a freshman, I can't
do anything for you right now.
However, it's a really
fascinating thing
to see the drive in these
young kids and the respect
that I have for them now.
This is the post-9/11 world.
In the Special
Operations community,
you will be going to war.
I joined selfishly as more of
a physical challenge, pre-9/11.
I was like, well, I can do that.
So it was a selfish thing.
I thought I'd be
traveling the world
and getting tattoos and
drinking in the Philippines.
And I did all the drinking,
got all the tattoos,
but I never went
to anywhere nice.
I spent all my time in Iraq and
Afghanistan and other places.
But I have such a respect
for these young kids
now, going in knowing
that if they make it,
they will go to war.
They want to serve at
that highest capacity.
I've only mentored officers,
except for this one guy who
was-- he reached out
first when he was--
I think he was a freshman
or sophomore in high school.
He's a good Christian
boy from Texas.
See?
Texas.
Told you guys.
And I was very polite,
and I was responsive.
And my wife was
like, come on, honey.
You don't have time to
respond to every high school
kid that reaches out,
wanting to be a SEAL.
There's a lot of them out there.
And I kept in touch, but I
was transparent with them.
I was like, there's not a whole
lot I can really do for you.
You're in East Texas,
I'm in San Diego,
and you're a sophomore
in high school.
You've got a few
years to go, buddy,
especially if you're going to
go in right after high school
and not college.
And he was so persistent,
so determined.
He just kept training
and training.
He kept in touch off and
on throughout the months
and years.
And then all of a sudden, I got
home from the office one day,
and I got a text, and it
said, hey, it's Garrett.
I just checked into BUD/S.
I was like, holy crap.
I was like, honey, he's here.
And I was like, come
on over to the house.
He is by far the most
disciplined individual
I have ever mentored.
Far more disciplined
than the officers,
which was kind of scary, because
they're in a leadership role.
But all he wants to do is
go to SEAL Team 6, which is
Naval Special Warfare
Development Group.
So if you want to aspire
to go to SEAL Team 6,
you have to be in the
regular SEAL teams
for at least four years,
have an immaculate record,
have all the qualifications
that you can only
get if your top ranked
in your platoon.
He's the lowest ranking--
he just turned 21, and he's
a sniper and a breacher
and a JTAC already.
A JTAC is the
important radio guy
that talks to the F-22
pilots, telling them
where to drop ordinance.
Kind of a big responsibility for
a 22-year-old or a 21-year-old.
But he's so emotionally
mature and so disciplined
in his approach.
He doesn't party.
He just studies and works out.
That's all he does.
He's the lowest ranking
guy in his troop,
yet he's the highest ranked,
as far as performance,
in his troop.
Very well respected.
And so he's a shoo-in for
going through the SEAL Team 6
selection process.
But it's just a really--
again, I take all the credit
for his success.
But it's just fascinating
to see these kids go through
so-- because mentorship is
as rewarding for the mentor
as it is for the mentee, at
least I've found that so.
Good question.
Thank you.
Yes.
Do we have time?
I don't know.
What time is it?
SPEAKER: Yes.
BRENT GLEESON: OK.
We're good.
AUDIENCE: Would you allow
or encourage your own sons
to Navy SEALs?
BRENT GLEESON: I
always get that one.
[LAUGHS] I would
like my parents--
my answer to this
is typically that I
would be cautiously optimistic.
Obviously, when I told
my parents about this,
my mom was somewhat devastated.
But then when 9/11 occurred,
she was very devastated.
And then when we found that we
would-- my task unit from SEAL
Team 5, back in 2003, we
were the very first SEALs
deployed into Iraq.
So she was also not super
thrilled about that.
Because you can go to
what's called CENTCOM, which
is the Central Command
for Afghanistan, Iraq,
Syria, or you go to PACOM, where
nothing is really going on,
Guam, Philippines,
Japan, you're just
doing training and exercises
and readiness drills.
But everybody wants to
go where the fight is.
And she wanted me to go
where the fight was not.
So I would be
cautiously optimistic.
I would be supportive.
I would never encourage it.
My dad was a marine
during Vietnam.
Never once did he ever encourage
me to go into the military.
If anything he was--
he was happy I had
a job after college.
So he was like, sweet.
Stick with that.
And I was like, I'm
going into the Navy.
He was like, what?
You have a job.
I just paid for four
years of college.
What are you doing?
But again, if there was
passion there and drive,
I would be very supportive.
I found this statistic
out recently,
because I do a lot of tours
of the training facility
to help raise money for
the SEAL Family Foundation
that I'm on the board of.
And they giving this tour,
and that question came up.
And they were like, well, how
often do the sons of SEALs
make it through training?
It's actually a funny statistic.
The answer was, guys, we're
not a family business.
Statistically, the sons of SEALs
are less likely to make it.
I don't know why that is.
I don't know if they go in
with a different approach
or some sort of an
entitled mindset thing.
Well, clearly, I've got the
blood of a SEAL warrior running
through my veins.
Obviously, this is going
to be a piece of cake.
And most of them quit.
Sometimes they get injured
and things like that.
But it's just the same risk that
my parents were worried about
of having a good
job out of college
and taking the risk to go
into the Navy for five years
and knowing that 90% will fail.
That their point
was, well, you're
kind of putting your life
on hold for five years
when you fail out of BUD/S.
So of course that gave me
the drive not to
fail out of BUD/S.
But I wouldn't encourage it,
but I would be supportive.
AUDIENCE: I had a question.
What did you tell your
brother when you made it?
BRENT GLEESON: [LAUGHS]
He was at graduation.
I was like, what's up, bro?
[LAUGHS] How are
you doing by that?
How's your career going?
[LAUGHS] He was--
any of the people in your life
that are naysayers, being like,
oh, that's probably
not a good decision.
I mean, again, once you
make it through Hell Week,
it's very unlikely
that you're not
going to make it all the way.
We weed 90% of the people
out in the first five weeks.
So within five weeks of being
at BUD/S, whoever was saying
you couldn't do it is
going to know that you can
or that you failed, like
they said you would.
So.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So of the people
who stuck it out and made it
till the end, how did
they keep themselves
motivated in the moment?
BRENT GLEESON: It's a good
question about keeping yourself
motivated in the moment.
Another interesting
piece of that is you
could never predict
the people who
will be standing at graduation.
Out of the 250 people,
it's not necessarily
the big, tattoo-covered,
musclebound macho guy,
or someone who is an Olympic
athlete, or anything.
You could never
hand-pick the people
who are standing at graduation.
It's going to be a total mix
of cognitively, mentally,
physically.
And everybody's journey
is totally different.
Some people are better at
self-motivation than others.
Some people lean on their boat
crew members or classmates
to help motivate them.
And everybody also has their
own specific challenges.
Sometimes they're not
the strongest swimmer,
so they're worried
about their swim times.
Or they're not the
strongest runner,
so they're worried
about their run times.
Because every phase
you go through BUD/S,
every evolution gets
more and more difficult.
Your run times have to get
increasingly dramatically
faster every two months.
Swim times have to get
dramatically faster.
So twice a week, you're always
doing a four-mile timed run
and a timed two-mile ocean swim.
Not the easiest thing
in the world to do,
but you have to make
these certain times.
So it's not just the physical
strain and the academic part
of it, because you're working
and getting your butt kicked.
Especially in the early days,
until 1 o'clock in the morning,
you've got to get up at 4:00
for your four-mile timed run,
and you have homework to do
and studying for your exam
tomorrow.
So you really get no
sleep, but then it's
also the stress and anxiety
of not just the academic side,
but all that difficult
evolutions you have to pass.
Because on most
of the evolutions
early on, whether it's
the drown-proofing or some
of these drills that
weed a lot of people
out because they're not
comfortable in the water,
it's the stress of not
passing those things.
So it's not just
the physical strain,
but the mental stress that if
you fail, at once, you're done.
I mean, that's it.
On most of these evolutions,
you get one chance.
So you can imagine
how stressful.
Every single day you get
out of bed, you're like--
I remember the anxiety of just
every morning, I would get up--
and this benefited
me later in life,
because I can now manage stress
like you couldn't believe.
If nobody's trying to blow me
up or shoot me in the face,
I'm good to go.
Any problem is a
problem that's solvable.
But I would get up
every morning at 4
o'clock just literally
wrought with anxiety,
knowing that one, I'm
going to get my butt
kicked all day long.
But two, what if I fail
one of these evolutions.
It wasn't so much self-doubt,
but knowing that the numbers
speak for themselves.
The statistics speak
for themselves.
And knowing that there was a
possible element of failure.
So the answer to your
question is that it's
different for every person.
Everybody has a
different journey
and their own
different challenges.
For me, it wasn't swimming or
running or specific evolutions.
I didn't have a lot of
problems with those.
It was the entirety of the
whole thing, and the grind,
and the stress physically
and mentally that was just--
it's just very hard to overcome
that level of stress, which
is also why oftentimes, the
guys out of high school,
the younger folks, don't make
it, because they haven't had,
really, any life experience.
They haven't-- you know,
they're coming from mom
and dad's house.
So oftentimes they don't
have the emotional maturity
or mental fortitude yet.
Not that being a
fraternity guy in college
really gets you ready
for SEAL training either,
but it's oftentimes
too why they just
don't have the mental fortitude
to handle that anxiety.
Well, thanks, guys.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for showing up.
Thank you, Wendy.
Thanks, Steve.
Appreciate it, guys.